this is what victory looks like for the
russian military
nearly two months into moscow's
so-called special military operation
and its defense minister is now
declaring his first major success
the armed forces of the russian
federation and the people's militia of
daniels people's republic have liberated
mariupol the remnants of the formation
of nationalists took refuge in
industrial zone of the azov style plant
the azov stall plant remains the last
stronghold for ukrainian troops in
mariopol who have refused to surrender
officials believe there are nearly 2 000
ukrainian fighters holed up in and
around the steel plant
for days russian officials have been
saying they are willing to allow
sporadic ceasefire periods to let them
surrender or they would have to storm
the plant
now the commander-in-chief of russia's
armed forces has other ideas
i consider the proposed storming of the
industrial area pointless i order to
abort it this is the case when we must
think that is we must always think but
even more so in this case about
preserving the life and health of our
soldiers and officers there's no need to
climb into these catacombs and crawl
underground through these industrial
facilities block off this industrial
area so that not even a fly comes
through
i know they captured most of mariopol a
long time ago we are very well aware of
that but there's a part of the city
where our servicemen remain and they
will stay there for now
this once thriving port city was home to
more than 400 000 people
now fewer than fifty thousand are left
unable to escape the fighting
as vladimir putin was being told a
victory in mariopol russian-backed
separatist fighters of donetsk announced
school was back in session
for the first time since the invasion on
february 24th
according to the donetsk people's
republic
721 children are going to school in
mariopol under its supervision
the separatists say moscow has sent
school books for these children
including textbooks under russian
language and russian history
children are glad to be alive to
communicate with each other they respect
elders some of them met their teachers
their school directors from previous
schools
posters reading for homeland for
russians for dumbass
all in russian cover the walls in these
schools
an indication of what's likely to come
as russian officials say it is now safe
for residents to return home
russian forces entered mariopol on march
11th now 42 days later they have claimed
victory but at what cost
it's not clear if anyone will return to
this ruined area to live under russian
occupation or who will be expected to
rebuild a city which now lays in ruins
dorsochapari al jazeera moscow
new satellite imagery is showing what
appears to be another mass grave this
one near ukraine's besieged city of
mariopol the private u.s firm maxar
released these images the mass grave is
around 20 kilometers from mariopol and
grew in size between march and mid-april
a local councillor says that russian
forces were seen transporting bodies to
that site
well as the russian offensive in the
east of ukraine continues al jazeera's
charles stratford reports now from
backwood in the donbass region
the great focus is on what is being
reported as around a thousand civilians
in those bunkers underneath that steel
works that is still certainly a section
of it we understand controlled by
ukrainian forces those pictures released
yesterday by the azoff battalion one of
the fighting forces that are inside that
steel plant showing families children
sitting on beds obviously having been
there for a long while
and increasing concerns on how those
civilians are going to be get out
now the azov themselves have released a
statement saying they want a
humanitarian corridor to get those
civilians out of that steel plant
as well as what they say is around 500
injured soldiers but we also know that
those fighters are refusing to surrender
and in that context despite vladimir
putin saying that basically it's victory
in mariopol and i think it's fair to say
that um it would be almost inconceivable
in fact it would be inconceivable for
those ukrainian fighters to be able to
push back
until that plant is cleared of ukrainian
forces he
any military analyst could would tell
you he doesn't have complete control
over that city so putin needs this
victory in mariopol
and just how he's going to get that
victory without potentially
a thousand civilians at least being
killed remains to be seen
the prime ministers of spain and denmark
have pledged their support to ukraine on
a visit to kiev they're the latest
european leaders to meet the ukrainian
president in recent weeks they also made
the trip to borodyanka outside the
capital where the bodies of nine
civilians were found overnight spain's
prime minister pedro sanchez condemned
what he called the atrocities of putin's
war on the streets of the town
well outside the capital kiev many
ukrainians are still surveying the
damage left by russian shelling al
jazeera's harder abdul hamid reports now
from urpin
well we're here actually at this
bridge
that leads out of european and this
place really has become iconic for all
the wrong reasons it had been detonated
as the russians were trying to advance
towards the capital
kiev uh you know if if you recall there
was these dramatic pictures of civilians
trying to flee
as quick as they can under the shelling
um
this car just looking at it you can just
imagine probably a family or someone in
there trying to run for their lives just
to find themselves at the bottom of the
river here
and we have no information what happened
to them
now down there under that under the
bridge that's where people were
running out trying as quick as they can
to flee the russian shelling
and also the crossfire because on the
other side you had some ukrainian forces
so the civilians basically were trapped
in the middle of all that now this image
of devastation is something that you
will see over and over again the more
you drive down that road after 18 there
is bucha also now becoming iconic for
all the wrong reasons